mr. president um I know you're close to
the Queen and she has a lot of affection
for you great visit so we have a great
relationship which would you be able to
give her any advice for some of the
rogue Royals like what's happening there
it seems like there's a lot of tumult
and you've been so good at keeping your
kids together and a close-knit family I
think it said I do I think it said she's
a great woman you know i sat with our
supposed to be with her 15 minutes I
stayed an hour and a half by the way I
got killed by the press she wanted me to
stay
the press said don't know he was
supposed to be there's very rude we had
a great time then we had dinner we were
honored our country was honored i sat
with her for a long time and she was
smiling and laughing the whole time we
had a glow it's important for her she
the tradition of the monarchy and the
responsibilities but we have a very
great relationship I think this was a
blindside she was blindsided by this
whole situation and I think it's too bad
but you know she's been the queen has to
be an all-time record from the time
she's like 25 and now she's 94 she's
never made a mistake if you look I mean
she's had like a flawless time I think
Harry should go back come back and well
I think I think you know I don't want to
get into the whole thing but I find it I
just have such respect for the Queen I
don't think this should be happening to
her IOC announced today and this is our
final question mr. president just
announced that no politics at the
upcoming Olympics new policy by any of
the athletes would you like to see that
extended to the United States where
politics stay out of sports I know
you're going to the big LSU game well I
am and I was responsible for getting the
Olympics the Olympics is coming to Los
Angeles and I was called by the mayor
and he said could you do us a favor when
I was president intellect and he said
could you do us then I worked very hard
and we got the Olympics and we have the
World Cup coming in to the United States
and I don't know I guess you can say
that no politics but people are gonna
talk politics I think politics I do
believe I've made politics somewhat more
exciting the New York Times would be
dead right now will be eliminated the
Washington Post will be out of business
I hate to say it but cable television
would be it's obsolete cable television
would be oedipus
so we'll go another hopefully five years
and we'll keep everybody happy great
thank you very much thank you very much